[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 doit dire tout de suite le
sommaire sports de combat non violent le
body karaté est un mélange de karaté et
de danse nous sommes allés au
rambouillet sports karaté pour tester
cette activité physique atypique
ce week-end la 20e édition de la fête du
miel revient à plaisir au programme
ateliers découverte par à miel et
produits du terroir
le détail des animations dans la
chronique de journalistes juste une
brasier et peut enfin l'agenda complet
de vos sorties du week end
au programme un spectacle un événement
versailles et et du cinéma
connaissez-vous le body karaté apparu
dans les années 2000 ce sont des
enchaînements de karaté fait sur de la
musique au rambouillet sports karaté
des cours sont donnés le vendredi soir à
20 heures j'ai voulu tester pour vous
cette pratique qui exige un certain
effort physique
le reportage avec bixente mérian senti
stéphane guillon différentes techniques
de karaté
le body karaté permet de se tonifier et
de s'assouplir
je suis donc accueilli aujourd'hui par
le club rambouillet sports karaté
on commence par une série
d'enchaînements assez facile au début où
tous les muscles sont sollicités aussi
bien mon bras que les jambes
j'écoute attentivement la professeur
véronique mesnil de vidéos multiple
championne de france de karaté par et
une demi heure que le cours a commenté
je suis un peu essoufflée nationale ça
va puisque une fois qu'on a après les
chorégraphies qu'elles sont assez
répétitive et bien c'est moins dur j'ai
parlé trop vite les enchaînements
s'accélère il faut avoir un bon cardio
alors là ça se complique les mouvements
sont plus dur est en fait plus on avance
dans le court plus c'est compliqué mais
bon je vais faire mon mieux dans ce
court d'amateur il y à des débutants
mais aussi des personnes comme siham qui
fait du karaté depuis l'âge de 13 ans
elle est venue découvrir ce nouveau
sport premier cours de body karaté est
ce que ça vous fait amènera le truc
traditionnel
le travail cardio travail et la suivrai
quoi on sert mais du coup il nous reste
peu de temps il reste combien de temps
de encore puisqu'un c'est juste à les
faire partir le cours de body karaté
s'est arrêté il y a dix ans se sont donc
grâce aux nombreuses demandes que ce
cours a rouvert pour la rentrée donc je
suis en présence de véronique mély de
vidéos qui la professeure de body karaté
oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer déjà qu est ce que le body
karaté alors le body karaté c'est des
enchaînements de karaté fait sur de la
musique encore ça permet de travailler
les chaînes musculaires
le cardio la respiration tout ceci dans
une bonne ambiance ça permet de gérer
son stress et il ya énormément talent
est ce que c'est normal
oui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que au
niveau de la fédération française de
karaté donc c'est la fédération qui a
mis en place le body karaté dans les
années 2000 il y à 90 % de femmes qui
pratiquent le body karaté dans notre
club on essaie d'inciter les hommes à
pratiquer le body karaté aussi et alors
pourquoi autant
pourquoi alors je pense que comme c'est
un petit peu
un mélange de danse avec le tempo de la
musique on le pratique en individuel il
n'y a aucun coup il n'y a pas de
problème de technicité on est moins
exigeant donc ça plaît beaucoup plus aux
femmes quatre hommes sur une petite
vingtaine de participants sont quand
même venus aujourd'hui et si vous aussi
vous voulez venir
[Musique]
toujours en sport l'eco trail de paris a
été annulé à cause de lakovic 19 cette
année mais sidy diallo un spécialiste du
marathon veut réaliser son propre eco
trail le trail evelyne paris samedi 3
octobre à 11 heures au départ de la zone
des manèges de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
tout le monde peut participer et le
parcours et la distance sont libres et
après le sport vient le réconfort et on
va parler d'alimentation aujourd'hui une
alimentation plus saine puisque ce week
end la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
propose samedi et dimanche alimentaire
divine plusieurs animations autour des
aliments sains et de bonne qualité que
propose la ferme mais aussi tous les
producteurs locaux du coin dans une
ambiance guinguette
interview express avec frédéric lieu le
responsable des animations de la ferme
l'idée c'est de vraiment faire le lien
or entre le consommateur et le
producteur von à petite échelle on a
effectivement deux fois par an un gros
marché fermier mais ça a marché fermier
nationale à l'idée c'est vraiment
d'associer finalement les producteurs
avec qui on a l'habitude de travailler
qui commercialise dans notre boutique de
l'enfant qui a trois ans jusqu'à jusqu'à
la personne du troisième âge
y a vraiment toutes les approches voilà
l'enfant il ya un espace d'animation
qu'on a baptisé tous en cuisine avec les
deux cuisiniers de la bergerie qui
pendant deux heures de 15 à 17 vont
concevoir imaginer une petite trois sets
d'un goûter avec les enfants donc voilà
ça c'est vraiment très adapté un enfant
le public adulte adulte pourra s'y
retrouver en faisant le tour du marché
où on pouvait en dégustant s'est tassé
de charcuterie fromage alors que les
personnes un peu plus âgés pourront
retrouver un ami patrice qui a une
collection d'objets agricoles
d'autrefois
en tout cas notre exploitation agricole
et en agriculture biologique
on a
la plupart des artisans qui sont là sont
de toute façon raisonnée mais mais
l'idée c'est d'aider c'est avant tout de
pouvoir expliquer le lien entre le
consommateur et le producteur sur une
base de confiance avec le projet
effectivement les produits les plus
impossibles et on reste dans
l'alimentation puisque la fête du miel
revient pour une 27e édition à plaisir
ce week end c'est l'association plaisir
village animation organise l'événement
dès 10h à 19h et pour en parler sur ce
plateau justin brasier vont soir forme
vous avez rencontré le président de
l'association exactement alors pourquoi
il fait du bel et bien une fête du miel
ou tout simplement pour promouvoir le
produit
bien sûr on le verra sur place il n'y
aura pas que du miel bien évidemment au
total 5 apiculteurs seront au
rendez-vous vous pourrez déguster leurs
produits et les acheter à savoir que ce
sont des apiculteurs locaux
il y aura bien sûr donc les apiculteurs
de la région parisienne donc on ne va
pas chercher des des produits qui nous
viennent du be2 du bout du monde nous
sommes donc uniquement les agriculteurs
qui se trouve donc soit sûr plaisir soit
sur elancourt ou soit sur villiers saint
frédéric et le conservatoire de
baignoires d'île de france
alors vous dites qu'il n'y aura pas que
du miel qu'est ce qu'il y aura d'autres
alors alors il y aura par exemple de
l'ail fumé un stand gastronomique
libanais des biscuits 22 exposants
seront présents et seront au rendez vous
sur place essentiellement locaux parce
qu'en fait il y aura des exceptions
comme le champagne ou encore le foie
gras
l'objectif c'est de valoriser les
produits en circuit court
il ya donc des boissons médiévales il y
à du champagne
il y à du foie gras il y adeux life
humains fabricant de pain à l'ancienne
avec un four à pain avec une
démonstration donc une situe la
fabrication de nos gars et alors est ce
qu'il ya des animations en plus des
stands
oui normalement il devrait y avoir
plusieurs animations notamment vous
l'avez entendu dans l'interview une
démonstration de fabrication de pain
artisanal mais aussi un panier garni de
ses produits locaux qui
va a gagné traditionnellement il ya
aussi un atelier grand public et
d'extraction de miel
mais cette année à cause de la crise
sanitaire ça risque de pas avoir lieu
et puis vous pourrez bien évidemment
déguster le miel de l'association qui
provient du château c'est un milieu qui
récoltait donc sur sur le château
plaisir donc ce sont les miels de notre
de notre du parc
c'est quelque chose qui est un produit
plutôt original puisque on est
sensiblement les seuls à avoir donc ce
type de miel sur le château qu'à la 27e
édition de la fête du miel ça se passe
sur l'ensemble du week-end les 2 et 3
octobre de 10 heures à 19 heures
l'entrée est gratuite et ça se passera
au château de la ville de plaisir
merci justin pour toutes les
informations les pays bas se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
chronique avec plaisir c est un
spectacle majestueux que nous offre
chaque année deux minutes à mi octobre
le parc animalier de l'espace
rambouillet le brame du cerf marque la
saison des amours et le nord sinoquet a
pu l'entendre par chance
voici le brame le cri caractéristiques
du cerf entre la mi août et la mi
octobre
c'est la période de reproduction du roi
de la forêt pour impressionner les
biches et de façon à repousser les
autres mâles lecerf pousse son brame
pour pouvoir transmettre ces gemmes à
l'espace rambouillet où la grande faune
forestière gambade dans les 180 hectares
de forêt faire entendre ce phénomène
naturel aux visiteurs est un moyen de
faire de la pédagogie tout le plaisir
que des gens vont prendre ici on espère
que c'est du plaisir qu'ils vont à
prayssas répercuter sur tous les milieux
naturels qu'ils iront voir après que ça
va les inciter à sortir à venir dans les
forêts et à venir dans avec beaucoup de
respect en fait par rapport au milieu
naturel
pour répondre à cet objectif le parc
animalier et forestier géré par l'office
national des forêts organise d'ailleurs
des animations dont le matin ou assez
tard le soir pendant toute la période du
brame un guide accompagne les curieux
pour aller au plus près des animaux mais
le parc est aussi ouvert toute la
journée pour qui souhaiterait partir en
quête de ce son si particulier
l'idée c'est de prendre l'air voilà
moi je ne connaissais pas l'espace
rambouillet donc ça me permet aussi de
découvrir
et puis parce que la période de brame
des cerfs donc c'est vraiment voilà lyon
me venaient pour ça va un peu tous les
animaux les sangliers et j'en ai déjà vu
ba des débuts et pourquoi pas des serres
les visiteurs qui auront eu la chance ou
non d'entendre le brame pourront dans
tous les cas venir à l'espace
rambouillet observer les naissances
issues de cette période de reproduction
les petits faons devrait naître en mai
ou juin prochain et si vous avez envie
de vous détendre à l'abri d'autres
activités sont prévues ce week end comme
le spectacle daara j family vendredi 2
octobre à 20h30 à la batterie à
guyancourt
venez découvrir ce duo de la scène hip
hop venant d'afrique et leurs textes
engagés écrit en wolof en anglais ou en
français
la 9e édition de la nuit de la création
fait son retour à versailles ce samedi
de 20h à 1h du matin un site ouvre donc
leurs portes gratuitement comme l'école
des beaux-arts le musée lambinet ou
encore l'espace richaud et puis enfin le
château de breteuil ouvre ses portes et
accueille pour une troisième édition ce
week end une cinquantaine de figurants
pour une reconstitution historique
militaire quatre périodes seront
représentés les templiers les écossais
jacobites les grenadiers et des
parachutistes américains
l'administrateur du château nous
embarque au cours de ces deux journées
eh bien ils vivent comme sur leur
campement
il ya la cuisine ni lé déjeuner il ya
des manoeuvres donc qu'ils vont défiler
également à deux reprises samedi après
midi et dimanche après midi un grand
défilé autour du miroir d'eau le grand
bassin qui est dans les jardins à la
française du château donc ce défilé va
duré une petite heure et à chaque fois
que chaque association présente son
époque beau public et c'est déjà la fin
de ses 7,8 loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles idées sorties même
endroit même heure
bonne soirée à jeudi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]